was it a scary situation where they
tried getting you up out of here and it
felt like they took you off TV it was
like it was they try to cancel me like
at least once a year well I mean no I
know but there was there was the time I
think uh it was a couple years ago and
you had the interview I forget I don't
want to get into it but that's I mean it
was a learning moment that you went
through with everybody 100 you know what
I mean but that's the thing like moments
like that uh either show your toughness
and show how quickly you could fold so
you know uh I think Martin Luther King
said it best it was like the test of the
true test of a man's character isn't in
times of comfort but in times of
controversy so that that just shows you
how solid I was to every Community to
where where most people instantly are
they they waver and we're like I leaned
into it and then we began to to
understand and really focus not only on
my business and saw who was riding with
me and who wasn't but then at the same
time uh any wrongdoings that I I made I
corrected as every man should and I
think we need to be more more uh I mean
it's kind of crazy because we don't give
a lot of people that opportunity anymore
yeah and I mean I got another show that
I'm creating uh right now that I already
created that we already shot that'll be
debuting pretty soon but literally does
what deals with that I mean I coined the
Frank Council culture it's not about
cancel culture it's Counter Culture
don't cancel one another Council one and
that [__] to take your brother and show
them how to shake it up and how to
really get it right and give them an
opportunity none of us are greater than
God and so we should allow him to be the
one to judge yeah I feel like in a time
where like we're so at least perceived I
think we have a lot more in common than
people would like to talk about yeah
they always say there's more uh there's
hilarities and differences small things
that people are far apart on but
everything else they they everyone loves
their family everyone wants to be safe
everyone wants to be Prosper but if you
don't agree on this or this it's like
you gotta hate the other person and I
think yeah and that's I mean a Buddhist
mentality is we are one without uh one
without none and none without one so in
that idea of like we got we need each
other to to operate and if we keep
allowing the powers that be to split us
up it really feels like it is some
powers that be [__] bro yeah like
because that's how they control you they
control you divide and conquer that's
right but if we really understand like
again like we got more similarities and
differences in in the [__] that we
bicker about is I mean that's one of the
things that is I say while and I was the
most Progressive show on television
because we can have people from two
different walks of life we can have
someone from the Jewish Community some
from the Muslim Community and they go at
it and hug it out at the end we can have
a homophobic person and a transgender
person go at it and hug it out at the
end because but they talk the most [__]
say the most stereotypical offensive
stuff but when you say it's up all the
Guides of family and comedy and humor we
we win so but when you allow that stuff
to be rooted in hate and therefore you
think you better than somebody else
because of your life experience for sure
vice versa that's where [__] goes wrong
yeah I think it's like people will talk
out of like people will make mistakes
and I think that's just human nature
yeah so if someone makes a mistake
that's not from a place exactly correct
talk to them yeah that's why they put a
races on pencils it's like yeah it's
like yo I don't [__] with Earthlings
so the new show that you're working on
is called it's called Council culture
yeah you know you're getting exclusive
here because I actually it wasn't
supposed to talk about that yet they uh
but yeah that's it's something I I kind
of realized man that uh when I was doing
my daytime talk show I was like this
ain't where the bag is you know what I
mean all of that Ellen money and Oprah
money they came and scooped all of that
up yeah it's kind of like they kind of
got the last of that yeah yeah so I went
in there I was like there's no way this
makes sense to make it takes 16 hours to
make one hour and the bandwidth of doing
it every day like it was trying to do
radio like it was literally draining me
so I had to step away so I was like I
want to be able to do the same thing
have the same type of impact but you
know Consolidated and do all episodes of
the Season or something yeah but really
what what even even on a daily
perspective it's like it has to be able
to be a part of my lifestyle opposed to
me trying to come here and show up for
work like I don't work for nobody so
like when if it feels like I got a job
then I'm I'm out but uh the fact that I
can actually live my life and document
the process and show the process and
actually truly help people and you know
the fact that I go to therapy a few
times a week how can I bring that to the
table the fact that you know I have
great relationships with the mothers and
my children and knowing how fascinated
and intrigued people are by my life how
can I offer that in a way to not only I
can be open and honest and control my
own narrative but then at the same time
you know monetize it